hello citizens of the reject nation
we are we are we are the reject of the
nation
all right guys we got the dc comic con
or the warner brothers one going on
right now johnny boys with us goose is
with us today a rooster a comic book
movie aficionado friend over here hey
gordon guys guys we are going to watch
the trailer today for
sam fury of the gods what i really
appreciate right now is if you could
leave a like shazam that like button
also subscribe and click the
notification bell that we can get
notified whatever else we are covering
for the rest of comic con today i also
wanted to give a quick mention today
that we have recently partnered up with
heavy spoilers and screen crush for a
one-stop nerd shop called zero edition
where you can get all of our high
quality apparel we got plenty of reject
inspired apparel to represent your pride
as a citizen of the reject nation we're
currently working with our artists on
even more designs right now and right
now we've got several stranger things
inspired designs and recently we did one
meets one equals one
anyway guys you can go support us by
checking out shop0edition.com anywho
let's get into this boys thank you for
helping me out with those talking points
let's get to it
[Music]
i'm an idiot
it's show time
i don't deserve these powers
what am i even contributing
wow
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and batman it's so
just me
wow
[Music]
that's nice
i feel like a fraud
it doesn't matter um anyway a wizard
gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers was
everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician
[Music]
business listen to me billy the fate of
your world depends on it
[Music]
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you
that's the furious movies lady it's all
about family
now where's jesus family guys that was a
signal did i not just pitch a short idea
just now
ah cool get together
yo i will not survive this
i don't know how we fight powers like
this
holy crap i think i know how to fix this
dude but i really don't
everyone can be worthy
let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
in the world right now
i just threw a truck and a dragon
i love my life
that looks like a blast that looks so
fun
what was the m m song in the first
trailer the the first movie because they
did an eminem song and now they're doing
uh oh man
yeah and they're doing this one it's
gonna drive me crazy now
yeah i mean in terms of uh you know
upgrade from first movie to a sequel
there's such a nice visual quality
aesthetic upgrade i do like that it is
exploring more of the god elements you
got hespera you got calypso something
tells me that you know like it looks
like they're trying to pitch helen
mirren as the main villain but i i'm
more under the impression that because
we barely saw lucy liu that she's
probably gonna be
more of the main villain uh this time
around and i like the setup that you
have here for billy kind of has like
this imposter syndrome i just want to
point out like i was kind of shocked
that they showed us ben affleck's batman
in this trailer
i know that he's live i know he's gonna
be showing up in the flash movie but i
really felt like dc has been at a point
like we still want you to like not think
about that anymore we don't want you to
think about that i'm like oh you just
showed us it front and center in this
trailer i know he's going to be coming
back up but i was i was really taken
aback by that but i like the anyway back
to the actual movie itself i do i do
like where they're setting up with billy
even feeling like he might not even
belong with his family right now such a
strong part of him finding family in the
first movie and now it's like he might
feel like he he's not even needed with
his family as he's coming into like how
old is billy going to be in this movie
he's an adult yet
like every i was thinking about the same
thing him and jack dylan grazer like all
the young people are going to look so
much older now but yeah what'd you think
johnny i was really dazzled by this like
i'm really looking forward to this a lot
but yeah just the way this looks like
it's building upon the first movie both
in terms of david's f sandberg's just
vision for it looks way more dazzling
and realized and for the dc eu what i
love about this is that it does
incorporate that sort of godly gravitas
and they're dealing with you know greek
gods again like we just saw in thor love
and thunder and i love that this feels a
bit different like yeah it has the color
and it has the life and the fun but it
also looks like it's going to utilize
the dc universe's particular flavor for
more menacing and more awe-inspiring
gods and and mythology and i love the
kind of blend that we see of that here i
was such a huge fan of the first film so
i'm glad that david f sandberg is you
know he's bringing back the comedy of
course i think the i mean for me just
from this trailer the action looks so
much more grand than what we got i mean
just it's just a teaser trailer but what
we got from the first film this feels a
lot like i said a lot more grand and
epic just in scope what what we've seen
so far i really like that they're tying
again back to the themes of the first
film this family and i love also too
it's starting to get really meta too
when he was with helen mirren's like
yeah really men like family and then
talking about fast and furious i thought
that was hysterical i mean this looks
like uh the david f sandberg's really up
in the andy in terms of comedy and
action so i'm really looking forward to
that and then seeing the two characters
of hespera and uh and calypso that looks
really cool they look like they're uh i
mean again slight tease but you know
gonna be an interesting to see like in
terms of the whole shazam shazamly as
you mentioned earlier you're gonna see
interesting gonna be formidable foes
that they're gonna be facing off with
also too uh they mentioned in the
trailer that they are the daughters of
atlas and fun little fact that i'm sure
most of you already know the acronym for
shazam one of the letters and one of the
words in there is actually atlas the
first one is
[ __ ]
exactly they're all gods yeah the first
one seemed like it was kind of leaning
into some horror aspects i i doubt
savannah's gonna return in this god i'm
liking on the caterpillar at the end
what's the name of that caterpillar i'm
flanking on the name mr mine mr mine
got no hint of him at all here
i'm like they're just gonna drop that
there'll be another tease at the end of
this movie yeah just come back to mr
mining at the very end but it also seems
like they're setting up for some type of
special dc cameo i'm opting for wonder
woman to appear in this film out of all
the cameos i feel like because of the
gods and stuff wonder woman seems like
the one that would appear in this film
if they were to get a dc cameo but only
from the neck down we were yeah and it
won't be problematic for anyone
we don't really see freddie in this
trailer we got the rachel
ziegler zeigler character uh we don't
get much of her so there's more to
unpack with this film as far as what we
got so far i'm excited for it this looks
great this looks like a really solid
sequel follow-up man i love it it looks
like the ceo we should have gotten for
big two and i imagine that the parents
one of them they gotta find out like it
seems like we're gonna get more merry in
the shazam lee now it seemed to have an
emphasis on her
and i imagine that they'll probably the
parents will they got to find out about
losing one of these kids
give him power to give the parents her
whole family oh yeah and jamon hansu as
the wizard is definitely getting way
more involved this time around it looks
like there's some type of personal
connection or vendetta that's between
sparrow and calypso uh in this film so
yeah got a lot to unpack
what are you doing i understood that
reference dude
there's other stuff coming up and we've
talked for 15 minutes we got to get this
done all right thank you guys for being
here subscribe click that bell leave a
like shop zero edition.com check out the
shirts let's go